hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video today we're gonna be doing
something a little bit different this is
a game called Kingdom under fire - thank
you - game Forge for sponsoring today's
video they were able to give me this
game a little bit early so I could play
test interview before the game is out by
the time you're seeing this video the
game had already been out so you can of
course buy the editions and everything
that we're gonna be talking about I will
be showing you because this is in the
full game this game actually used to
exist back in the eastern side of the
world for a very long time but it has
since finally come to the West so
awesome erican players Canadians you
know South American players can finally
get to play this game now first up this
game is going to be only on PC and
there's going to be three different
packages that you can buy the hero
package the emperor package and the war
god package hero is 30 Emperor is 50 and
the war god is 100 each coming with its
own unique stuff all of these additions
are going to be giving you the full game
with the hero package giving you one
exclusive costume as well as some
benefits that are miscellaneous and germ
troop benefits the emperor package is
going to give you 2 exclusive costumes
one of which was from the previous
Edition and a new mount as well as the
troop and miscellaneous benefits and the
Beauregard package as you guessed it is
going to have the to exclusive costumes
from the past editions and a new one in
this one as well as two mounts and of
course more true benefits and other
benefits as well these troop benefits
include troop coupons troop revival rare
troops epic troops with the other
benefits being booster packs change
appearance vouchers resurrection tickets
character slot expansions as you can see
the $50 one is definitely one of the
more popular ones that people like to
grab and especially if you're big on
customization having unique things
because you cannot find these anywhere
else I would definitely grab the higher
editions but if you don't want to grab
any of those and you just want to play
the game the $30 Edition is there for
you now this game is very interesting
because it's a Buy to play MMO and RTS
hybrid it's very confusing in a sense
when you first think of it but as soon
as you start the game it gets a little
bit better MMO just like your standard
MMO titles with some RTS battles which
we'll get into later in the video and
showcase the game currently has five
playable classes being gunslinger spell
sword berserker Ranger and elementalist
each being gender locked at the moment
the game also has loads of different
troops like sorcerers orcs bowmen
mortarmen and a bunch of different
things like wizards and anything that
you can really think of
we're
- what those troops are like I said
later in the video but just to let you
know there's a loads of different things
to add to your army I ended up playing
as all five characters to really
understand what kind of abilities
they're getting but you'll for majority
of the gameplay you'll be seeing this
spell sword 1 because it's actually one
of my favorite characters and you know
for the easy thumbnail the character
creation for this game is one of the
more advanced things that I've seen in a
very long time with the recent mmo's
what you're going to be seeing is a lot
of previews in the bottom left as well
as a background cover to kind of
understand what the lighting looks like
for the character the preview isn't
going to be your default armor but
essentially saying hey this is the low
tier armor the mid tier and the endgame
armor and what it kind of looks like
with the character you can of course
change the hair color the eye color the
skin tone the lip color even go as far
as changing the actual face
reconstruction the hair style the color
of that decorations like tattoos or
piercings or anything like that on the
face or if you don't really know what to
do with your character or maybe you just
want to test out the character and don't
really feel like doing customization you
can go in the top left for the presets
and then we'll give you a whole new
character or if you have the basic stuff
down but just want to customize the
facial reconstruction and the bottom
right it has a random which is going to
randomize the face shape the eyes or
anything that has to do at the face
after creating your character the game
prompts you if you want to choose the
tutorial or not if this is are your 2nd
3rd 4th 5th character then obviously you
probably don't want to do the tutorial
but obviously on your first character
you definitely want to see the
understanding the game and the game is a
very good way of explaining what the
basics of how this game operates is you
could see from the game point that this
gives me a weird dynasty warriors feel
weird this giant person going up against
loads of different enemies killing like
18 to 20 of them at a time which I
personally love it gives it a really
nice feel of the war and it actually
feels like a giant war going on and not
just five people fighting five different
people there's actually large-scale
combat with hundreds and hundreds of
troops fighting at one time one thing I
do have to appreciate though is how
insane these cutscenes are one of the
things I definitely noticed is that I
actually really wasn't skipping
cutscenes even on multiple characters
because about the cool these things look
obviously they're not mocap 20:19
graphics where they look absolutely
real-life but for an MMO like this it
actually looks and astonishing the other
thing I must praise about this game is
how minimalistic the HUD is one of the
problems I had with PC and the Mo's is
that there's so much going on with the
amount of abilities and types of quests
that are happening is that because of
that there's so much happening on your
screen and it gets very claustrophobic
but the
game does a very good job of minimizing
how much is on screen by not giving you
exactly every single detail but
paraphrasing some things like on the
quests and showing you different icons
so that you know what you're doing
without having to be claustrophobic on
your screen now each character when you
hop into the game is going to have
multiple different menus you got your
inventory your skills your backpack your
map everything like that is going to be
there as well as the store which you can
of course purchase and things with
diamonds sometimes you don't have to you
of course don't have to buy the diamonds
yourself that's going to cost real world
money so if you don't want to do that
you totally don't have to but one thing
I noticed is that there's a mastery list
a skill list and a combo list and the
combo list had actually piqued my
interest because certain attacks can
actually combo into others and depending
on which way you use them you can
actually have different types of moves
for example one of the moves is just
tapping left-click that's your basic
attack well if you end up on locking
this part in the combo list you can
actually do left click then right click
afterwards to do a small little to hit
combo it's nothing crazy but it's a lot
better than constantly pressing one
button though all the time and button
mashing cuz that gets boring after a
while the quests are what you would
typically find in an MMO where they're
going to be small sometimes meaningless
quests were oh go kill this enemy go
light this fire go pick up these things
they're all gonna give you XP of course
but the real stuff is going to be the
dungeons which we'll talk about in a
little bit after we discussed the
individual characters the first
character is the gunslinger he's gonna
be your main attacker main dps type
character he doesn't have the most
amount of health but he's definitely
your all-around good character and
especially a very good beginner
character if you want to learn the ropes
of how to play Kingdom under fire - he
wields a sword and a pistol in the
second hand with a bunch of abilities
that either let you go from sword to gun
or just use the gun straight up and you
can use art to reload the gun it's
actually really cool and a lot of
different abilities that flow together
with the character your spell sword is
going to be your mage of the game she
has a bunch of things channeling the
magic of ice and lightning and using
those runes to go back and forth and
doing a bunch of elemental damage when
executed correctly she has these really
powerful runes that can actually rehear
yourself and that the reason they have
that is because she actually has a very
small health pool so she can keep
herself afloat so if you need somebody
that needs to just survive she's also
one of those characters speaking of
characters survive
we have the main take of the game the
Berserker this absolutely beefy looking
guy is definitely the biggest character
I've ever seen in a while
he is definitely your tank he is super
good at attacking multiple enemies at
the same exact time with his large
sweeping attacks and his giant sword you
can combine sword attacks with the
powerful core of rage in your hand doing
multiple different moves like slashing
sideways and then lifting the sword up
while using the rampage rune and a bunch
of other things in viewing your weapon
with dark energy and a bunch of
different things like I said to keep the
enemies focused on you and away from
your team the Rangers up next I find her
very opposite of the Berserker she has
very quick ranged and melee combat
attacks the problem is that while
inflicting very high damage just like
the Berserker she lacks the ability to
do a lot of damage when confronted by a
huge team of opponents so with the
Berserker he's really good at multiple
opponents whereas the Rangers were the
good at single target and the
elementalist
is a very skilled and versatile maid she
can use a bunch of things Dee buffing
and buffing opponents buffing your team
to give you more attack while also Dee
buffing the enemy team to give them less
defense and if that's not enough I like
to call the Beast masters because she
can use her magic to summon a bunch of
different companions to fight alongside
her one of the first ones you get is a
giant bear now we got to talk about the
real-time strategy within this game
especially within the one dungeon that
you first get at level 4 as the
commander of the army you have three
different options you have the C the X
and the Z key the C key is basically all
of your units follow you the x key is
the defense and the z key is your main
offense you can use the F keys at the
very top like f1 and f2 to go in between
different types of troops and selector
and unique abilities for example if you
highlight the archer troop you can
actually give them a damage boost to
their archery making them do a lot more
damage to flying targets or any big
targets that happen to be in your way
and towards the end of the dungeon
there's this huge large-scale fight
which looks absolutely insane after
after you've been using all of your
abilities and it's just really crazy how
having you can have a bunch of archers
in the back firing at the big scorpion
have a small little troop follow you to
the left with the other people staying
on defense towards the line protecting
the archers it's this huge strategy game
as well as being an MMO Alem one that
was basically the general overview of
the game Kingdom under fire - like I
said this game is available right now at
the time of this video is going
so if you do have a PC you definitely
want to play this game then difficult
click the link in the description down
below you can use that link to go get
the game as well as guys like to view if
you do enjoy subscribe if you're new
think you'd gain Forge for sponsoring
this video and peace out guys have a
great astir day goodbye
[Music]
[Music]